on today's show we talked to a woman
who's worried about her sister's new
relationship
we talked to a mom who wants to have
hard conversations with her kids
and herself we talked to a man whose
wife is overwhelmed with grad school
and he may or may not be the problem
stay tuned
hey what's up good folks i'm john and
this is the dr
john dalone show thanks for hanging out
with us there's about 11 billion other
podcasts you can be listening to
and you chose this one and we are so
glad you're here
we talk about relationships mental
health life
education parenting marriage what's
left of your everything we can think of
grief all of it
if you want to be on this show i'd love
to talk to you directly
personally i'd love for you to be able
to tell your story to all the listeners
out there so give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693
or you can go to not www but just
johndaloni.com show because it is the
21st century
fill out the form and it will go to
kelly and she is the gatekeeper of
my life now listen um one of the
the things that drives me bananas over
the last
i don't know 25 30 years uh is this
obsession that we have with
using machines and computers as
analogies for people
and you know i'm trying to think of like
he really downloaded that information or
um what's another one got like just a
computer analogy or
yeah we got our wires crossed or um
this is you know downloading new info
into your
i just don't like it because it ends up
we end up treating each other like
machines or like computers
but last night i think i experienced
something
that makes me rethink all that so i was
trying to put my five-year-old daughter
to bed
and i was like i need to brush her hair
i like the hair brushing process it
gives me the opportunity to touch around
the face to
calm everybody down tell some jokes and
to listen to whatever story she's got
for the day and her stories are
awesome and she wouldn't
come like to where i could brush her
hair so i handed her the brush i was
like hey you do it
and then i came back and she was off
gallivanting around the house
our house isn't that big there's not a
lot of gallivanting that can be done but
she was
jumping flying running thing around and
i said hey come here i need to brush her
hair
so she started walking my direction and
then i got distracted and then all of a
sudden it would turn into the third time
and i was like hey i need you to come
here so i can brush your hair and you
can go to bed
and she whipped around and looked at me
with all the sincerity she could muster
in her tiny five-year-old little body
and it wasn't like she was playing this
is like came from her soul
and she looked at me with this sense of
longing and passion
and frustration and so
here's here's how it all went hey i need
you to come here so i can brush your
hair it's the third time i've asked
but daddy i'm an owl
and evidently my brain has a pause
button because it just stopped working
i i didn't have an answer to that i
didn't know what to like what
i just looked at her and then she just
turned and i guess in her head flew
but i watched her walk and then she just
went and got in bed
and i probably should have had some sort
of response but i didn't know what to
say
because in my brain when i say hey um
come on
let me brush your hair there is a
multiple like layered responses like
okay dad
since you're the dad i'll come do it you
say or no i don't like you
and then there's like choose your own
adventure that way or there's
well can i get a snack there's all kinds
of things but
passionately decrying dad
i'm an owl i i don't really know what to
say so for everyone who i've
i've hurt your feelings about the
computers and machine thing
i may be wrong i think my brain is a
machine
because it clearly stopped working for a
moment last night
and it just sort of rebooted this
morning can i see what i did there just
came back online
now we're talking oh man so we've got a
action-packed adventure show today
that's kind of probably over dramatic
but we do have some awesome calls lined
up here let's go to amy in raleigh north
carolina good morning amy how are you
doing
hey john i'm doing well how are you
awesome hey do you have any uh little
kids
i well i have four kids yeah they're 11
and under
oh good god almighty so you're in it so
listen
do they ever say anything your brain
just just pauses for a minute
absolutely okay well good i'm feeling
like i'm losing it so i'm
so happy that you said that and i don't
even know why you're calling so let's
get to that all right so what's going on
amy how can i help
well i would like some guidance on how
i can express my concerns to my sister
about her rapidly advancing relationship
her rapidly advancing relationship so is
she in love love with somebody that you
don't like
yes but there's a lot of details
surrounding it that are highly
concerning to me
okay go for it um well she discovered
in february that her husband of nine
years was having an affair
and with by the end of the month he had
made contact with new people
and um found a person from her past
um she didn't really know well but like
you know over 15 years ago she knew this
person
and um within a week they had met again
we live on opposite sides of the country
um so she flew across the country to
meet this person and then within a week
or a week and a half after that they're
professing love for each other
and um he's planning to move in with her
um and she has two small children and
he's gonna move all the way back across
the country to go move in with her and
her children and i'm just like
and my husband and i met him also and
all of our
sirens are going off that this is like
not a person we trust
hey this dude this guy won the lottery
man some old girlfriend reached out to
him and is like hey you want free
free rent and me and he was like okay
okay
yeah this works out great for him huh
right
right and he's like he's um eight or
nine years older than her
he seems kind of a mess you know he
rents an apartment with some other
person who kind of
seems to want him out and then my sister
comes in and i don't even
last i talked to her she still hadn't
filed divorce papers yet
um her current husband has already moved
out and so she's just ready to move this
guy
right in yeah and of course being the
sister that i am i
went down to the courthouse and looked
up his records and
i didn't find things that were great and
i even discovered a lawsuit where he was
sued for basically not getting out of a
place i don't know the details
surrounding but
all of it's very concerning and uh she
has a two and a four-year-old
and i'm just i don't want her to think
that i am not happy for her
i'm worried if i say something or i
don't want to say something wrong you
know where
where he'll tell her manipulate her and
make her think oh they're just jealous
of our love that kind of thing
yeah wow that's a mess
um how long was your sister marry for
i think about nine years okay yeah you
said that how good is y'all's
relationship
i think it's really good we're really
close so
have you when you've kind of hinted
around this or
asked like really well this is what
we're doing how has she responded
um i think i've raised a few concerns um
she's kind of in a mode where she's not
like herself she's she's very much like
a different person and i think she just
thinks that
it's hard for people to understand so
she's like okay you know it's just it's
really hard for people to wrap their
their minds around
you know the fact that i'm in love and
i've got this fairytale man
and you know and i like i don't know i
don't think that's so
man okay so here's a couple things i
i would throw out for her sake and
then here's i'll just i'll give you some
of my thoughts here
i'm smiling because everyone who falls
in love
especially after a heartbreak or a
tragedy
they look around and it's so
intoxicating
that they think everyone else is crazy
and it's so hard because as someone who
loves someone in that situation
we often just have to ride it out right
it just and it's so painful because you
know how it's going to end
you know how it's going to end right
yeah
so um sometimes i give people a pass
on the quick turnaround time after
something like this and here's why
there are chances that her marriage has
been
dead for years yeah and it
may have or been on life support for
years
and so she may have um
had one foot one half of her heart two
feet
out the door and not even realized it
for a long long time
and then it just takes something like
this big reveal which she may have known
about
um maybe not intellectually but she knew
in her soul or
she did know about it or she just
blindsided right which makes this a
super trauma the whole thing's traumatic
regardless but
it may have been dead for a long time so
often when we see a
this is different than somebody passes
away in a car wreck right
um where it literally just snap your
fingers is over
this may have been running for a long
time that still doesn't make this
wise at all right so
my question for you is what is your
um or what statement here
so let's say you get the courage and it
would be hard right you get the courage
you go
sit down with her you look her in the
eye and say i think you're making a
terrible mistake
absolutely bonkers terrible mistake and
she says i hate you you're the worst
sister ever you've never loved me or
supported me in fact my husband cheated
on me because it's your fault i mean
just
all the stuff she could throw at you
what is your or what statement are you
gonna
disassociate yourself from her are you
going to back down from her
or are you just feeling powerless right
now because you're going to still love
her she's still going to be your sister
you're still going to hang out with her
and you're just watching a slow-motion
car wreck which one of those is it
no it's definitely the latter okay so
you don't have like an
or what or if then statement no
okay so if somebody's at a point where
i'm about to draw a real firm boundary
that i know
might really impact this relationship in
a negative way
that's one conversation this
conversation is a little bit different
it's a little bit easier and a little
bit
harder for you okay here's my
recommendation
i would take her out somewhere and
get her to tell you about this guy why
is he so wonderful
and you can ask the gentle questions
about
this seems super fast and i'm concerned
and i love you
and then the final statement i learned
this from one of my counseling
professors dr hendricks and i love it
which is
i'm worried about you and your future
but you're a grown-up
and i want you to know i'm going to be
here when things are great
i'm going to be here when things are
hard and i'm going to be here if things
completely fall apart
and and and um i'm always going to be
concerned for those kids
and so if you ever need anything let me
know and what that does is it
it rings a bell for some folks that
you're not trying to judge them
that you are literally walking alongside
them and you just recognize that they
let your hand go
and some folks are like okay whatever
dude but then they remember that when
things fall apart and it may be two
months three months seven months
um or seven years but that you will be
the first call they can make
and beyond that there's not a lot you
can do which is really really scary
um do you think this guy is unsafe for
those kids or does he just look like a
bum
i don't know i i don't i wouldn't let
him around my children
um okay so why not why not
um that's a bold statement told her that
if if they come and you know visit
you know who's gonna move in than they
were because she lives in arizona i'm in
north carolina
oh so you're far apart okay right so and
he lives here in north carolina so he's
moving out there with her
so they had talked about coming to visit
this summer we said of course they can
stay with us
but then after we met him i there's i
can't put my finger on it
but both my husband and i were like we
can visit with him we can have a cookout
with him
he is not staying in our home um and
we're not generally closed off like that
but we have four kids
and i'm like i wouldn't trust him near
my children
and so so what is it what's the thing
what's the thing i
i wouldn't thousand percent trust your
intuition here right i i
never push back on this intuition but
i'm i'm wondering what is it i think
part of it i mean there's something
about his essence or something
the control he's he's been able to um
you know kind of exert over my sister
and make her very different and she's my
older sister she's always been
responsible
very financially independent very
intelligent and he's had this effect on
her and i'm
you know she's behaved differently
around her own children you know when i
when i hear her talk to them and it's
just concerning that
what could happen in that home now that
boyfriend's kind of a center in the
obsession
um i i just worry yeah like it would i
don't know i'm like would they be taken
care of like
could he hurt them you know so
yeah my mom's signals are going crazy
yeah and
all the things you just said are are the
answer is yes he could hurt him
and if their mom is i love that
he's a drug right now right she's
grieving he's a drug
and if mom is willing to
do drugs with kids in the house then
yeah
he could hurt him he's gonna have access
so yes
as your sist as her sister as the um
as a responsible citizen right as their
aunt
yeah you got to keep that antenna up you
know to make sure that things are
they're safe and that you're not hearing
anything bonkers or weird
and um they're so so little and so young
right it's not like you can call them on
a side conversation like if they were
teenagers
um so based on that i might have a
little more direct conversation with her
a little more a little harder
conversation about hey what are you
doing
this is not smart not wise and maybe
tell her i love you so much i'm willing
to
um cause a rift in our relationship
right now
but this is not smart not why is it not
safe you don't know this guy
and moving in is too soon too fast right
um you could try that it's probably not
going to work
it's probably going to be messy um but
at least when this thing starts getting
the rail start
coming off she'll know that you love her
but again sometimes
if you make yourself so unsafe she'll
feel like she's got no one to call
right um but we are just so i'm
i'm more interested in a long-term
relational play here but
um yeah i
at the end of the day you can't do
anything about this that's that's the
hard part
you can have a gentle conversation you
can have a flexed conversation you can
have an angry
i'm the aunt of these kids i don't trust
this guy something about him
it's not ringing true to me it's not
safe what are you doing
any three of those situations may work
they probably won't
and what you're going for now is a
long-term relational play
like i said so that she reaches out to
you when when things go sideways which
they probably will
and if you ever get a hint an inkling
any sort of
as you said i love it any sort of
essence that the kids aren't safe
that they aren't doing okay that they're
being neglected that they're being
treated bad
you call every alarm that you know you
call every person
every community member every police
officer you call everybody
and make sure those kids are safe and
taken care of okay
i hate this for you and your family this
is hard this is a mess
stay with your sister and make sure that
she knows that you love her
and um and take care of yourself because
this is going to get heavy so you and
your husband instead of sitting over
there just having all these judgment
conversations that guy sucks and what
she doing our
check in with each other hey how are you
doing on this because i know this is
hard i know you love your sister and
give each other spaces to be frustrated
give each other spaces to be sad and
degree of this
and then to go about controlling things
you can control and you can't control
knuckleheaded older sisters for sure
thank you so much for that call amy
all right let's go to monica in salt
lake city
monica good morning how are we doing i'm
doing okay how are you
just rocking and rolling figuring it out
awesome so what's up how can i help so
as a conservative christian how
do i teach my kids accurate information
on lgbtq plus
issues while maintaining biblical
teachings on the subject
well that's a great question um so dig
into that a little bit
tell me what's behind that um just like
one of my kids is getting older and how
old um
okay and it's something that's going to
start coming up more and more as she
gets older i want her to have
good information so she can know you
know what other people might be going
through if it comes up for her what she
might be going through
um and you know just so that we can
raise them with a christ-like compassion
to where
they can love um has the love of god and
all mankind
hmm number one i love your heart here
man it's
it's so good here there feels like
there's another side to this so
are you are you afraid that teaching
them hospitality
is going to set them up in a like what
what's the other the or what part of
this
the or what part of it is probably um
you know okay this sounds terrible but
you know what if they come out what kind
of mom am i going to be
am i going to mourn that and not support
them you know
obviously they're young i don't know
they don't know but if it does come up
when they're older
um you know how do we navigate that if
that comes up so is this more about
you wanting to teach them is this more
about you
prepping for a conversation
that almost pre-worrying about a
situation that may or may not come down
the road someday
yeah and then my own i'm trying to
navigate through my own discomfort
with the issue as well well number one i
appreciate you being honest and
being brave early on in the show we
received a number of phone calls
and i i finally just asked on this topic
and when i was still practicing so those
shows didn't air just because i was
terrible to know what i was doing um but
one time i just asked hey
why are you calling me like why don't
you ask your friends
and the response was haunting the
response was
deloney i got nobody to ask and
i i've just been so fortunate to have
such a great community over the years
and so i
i'm so grateful that you reached out i
know so many folks are working through
this and thinking through these
these things and wanting to be graceful
and
loving so um to answer your first
question you're going to love your kid
the fact that your calling lets me know
that you're gonna you're gonna love your
kid
every mom every dad on planet earth has
this imaginary picture for their child
of what that's gonna look like
and 99.9 of them are wrong right
they're not gonna look that way and it
and it's
not just on this topic in fact it's
rarely on this topic it's about i wanted
him to be a baseball player or a lawyer
or a doctor or i thought they were gonna
marry somebody with dark hair or blonde
hair whatever the thing is
and so if this comes up hey you're going
to love your kid
b you're going to mourn the picture that
you had in your head it just plopped in
there whether society put it in there
you put it in there your parents put it
whatever it came from
right my wife talks about this future
thanksgiving table someday
and and when our kids come home from
college and yada
and i just smile because it's not going
to happen but it's so fun to think about
right
so um both of those things can be true
so here's here's my thoughts and i'm
going to like be as honest as i can i've
got
um a lot of
lgbtq friends and i've got a lot of
community members i mean that's uh
that's been my world as hospitality
over the last 10 15 20 years so
your impulse is first is right it's
hospitality first
like just understand how hard it is for
folks whatever they're walking through
each day
it's just hard right the second thing is
you can't undermine
christian teaching you can undermine
your faith's witness
and what i mean by that is as a
christian
person um and i'm one too so i'll speak
to the preacher the choir here
um we have to hold in our hands this
idea that we are looking for truth and
trying to
feel and read and be taught truth and at
the same time recognize that throughout
history we've been wrong
a lot and we've been right a lot we do a
lot of good in the world
christian communities a lot a lot of
good and
we've been really really wrong and so
what i have shifted over the last decade
is less of a focus
on i'm being right on all these topics
and issues
and shifted way more towards everybody's
welcome at delony's house
everybody's welcome at my table and we
will navigate relationships together
we will navigate topics together but
every one of those quote unquote what's
the right answer will always be done in
relationships right
um and then just for whatever it's worth
for you there are so many
there's such a diverse array of
faith-based voices out there now
when you said conservative christian
that means 50 different things to 50
different people
i'm interested in your definition what
does that mean to you
um i think it means more i guess
traditional christian
okay um so what so i'll even push
like so what does that even mean you've
got john wesley and john calvin
and martin luther and the catholic
community i mean that means
so many things um what is what is that
what does that mean so i guess when i
say conservative christian
to this topic i mean um
you know sorry this is a hard topic
because you know i feel like the worst
person ever having my viewpoints being
kind of behind
um hold on for a second hold on a second
you're not the worst person here's why
you're asking questions you are asking
questions and you are wrestling with
hard things right so you're not the
worst person
right if you were yelling on the side of
the street throwing rocks at people
then i would lump you into that's not
cool category but the fact that you're
asking questions
uh makes you a truth seeker and the fact
that you're asking relationships to
people
and not to alexa tells me you want
relationships and those that's i mean
that's the two greatest things
a person can be doing right now so good
for you okay
um so go ahead
um so you know traditionally marriage
um ideally is between a man and woman i
mean
um ideally like i if i have friends who
are in that community and get married
you know i'll go to their wedding great
for them this is
you know totally happy for them um
you know but just again marriage between
men and women is ideal
um i think that's what i mean okay
conservative christian so just the
picture of marriage there
yeah okay and let's like in the
relationship stuff and
everything up and down and um
middle schoolers being asked to declare
and what what's the right this and
what's right that
what i want to always push you back
towards which is this is where you're at
by the way is relationship and
hospitality
right and focusing less on having all
the right answers
and having all of the deepest
relationships possible
here's the the challenging thing um
we have we have decided some things in
our faith communities over the years
over all those different branches of of
christianity for what that means
and we have focused on some things
not focused on other things chosen some
things not just
every group has different thoughts and
and
um threads that run through it sexual
stewardship is
is a big one giving is a big one
hospitality is a big one
loving your neighbor as yourself is a
big one right and so
for you and your family for you and your
faith community
um defaulting to relationship and
hospitality don't be scared of yourself
and what might happen with your kid
someday
i can tell you right now you're gonna
love your child y'all may have hard
conversations
and spoiler alert even if your kid ends
up
not being a member of the lgbt community
you're still going to have a ton of hard
conversations together right
yeah what is it about yourself that you
don't trust
about compassion about care because you
sound like a loving person
you sound almost like you're ashamed of
asking hard questions
you know it probably goes back to the
way i was raised i was raised by
um unfortunately people who weren't
as loving and so i guess it's
you know kind of ingrained in me to be
judgmental and less loving
and i don't want to be that person you
know that's not
in me who i am but it's kind of part of
me at the same time because it's what i
grew up with
but here's what's making me smile right
now and you can't see it but i'm smiling
real big because
chances are the folks who raised you did
the best they could with the tools ahead
in their tool kit right
and they did the best they could with
what they knew with the air they were
breathing in the water they were
drinking
and what you're doing is like that old
maya angelou quote you do the best that
you can and then when you know more
you do better and that's what you're
trying to do right you're trying to be
less dogmatic and more in love with
people it doesn't mean that we throw
all the baby out the bath water there is
some ways of living that we got to hang
on to
right there is some discipline and
accountability
and quote unquote right ways of living
there are
and i'll go to task with anybody who
says no dude it's just whatever you feel
bro it's all cool it's not all cool
it's a mess right but all of that starts
in relationship
and i don't know what to tell you other
than i think you are
absolutely on the right track and here's
the thing the right track doesn't mean
that you and i
end up believing the same things on
everything it does mean that we end up
with an understanding we're going to
treat people with respect and dignity
wherever they happen to fall
does that make sense yeah that makes
sense
so i don't know that i'm answering your
question as much as affirming you
as somebody who is trying to navigate a
messy messy situation in a messy messy
world and trying to reckon with her past
and thoughts you may have had and jokes
you may have told and
and people you may have told off and
arguments you may have thought you have
won
with this new person who's looking at
their 10 year old thinking you are
inheriting a totally different world
than i come from and i don't know any
way forward other than to lead on love
and relationship
yes with discipline yes with it's
following
finding truth in rightness as best as we
possibly can
but man it is it is love and
relationship first and then we figure
out the rest as we go
i i think you're i think your kids are
lucky to have you as their mom
one of the greatest gifts listen one of
the greatest gifts monica my mom
and dad have given me is the fact that
they were both
super conservative christians over time
i would still consider them super
conservative christians
and i can't tell you the number of times
they've told me i changed my mind
i was wrong on this and i need to think
about it this way now
and that is a that over the the this
particular issue
that's the greatest gift that i look at
them and they're in their 70s now
and they hold really firm to some some
truths and they have said i
changed my mind on this one or i'm still
wrestling with this one i changed my
mind and i changed it back and now i'm
thinking about changing it again
all of it has just been this loop but
for me like i said
less than this is the way
it has been here's how we're gonna
approach it
we're gonna try to figure out we're
gonna always be trying to read something
that makes us uncomfortable we're gonna
always be trying to have hard
conversations we're gonna always be
meeting with the least of these and the
marginalized and those who are hurting
in our communities whoever
and wherever they end up being and then
we're gonna try to wrap our heads around
what that means in light of
this ancient text that we hang on to
and we're going to be challenged and
frustrated and ask hard questions
and we're going to come back to love and
we're going to get angry and we're going
to have to look at our neighbor and say
hey i totally disagree with you
i actually at the end of the day have
worked hard on this and i think this is
this is a universal truth here but come
over
have a glass of wine and we're gonna
figure it out you're always welcome at
my house
and man i think your kids are lucky to
have you monica
thank you so much for your heart
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy
video chat text chat phone counseling
it's a licensed therapist whenever and
wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com slash
deloney
for 10 off your first month it's cheaper
and it's available
all the time this is for you your family
and for everyone else that's coming your
way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.comtoday
all right let's take one more call let's
go to paul in carson city paul what's up
brother
not much how are you man we are rocking
and rolling dude what's going on man
hey so my question um
is about my wife so she is about
a year away from finishing her
undergraduate degree okay
and following that she wants to go to
physical therapy school
and that's three more years of school
which is probably gonna be a lot harder
and more time consuming but
uh my question is she really
hasn't handled her undergraduate degree
super well
emotionally you know it's been really
really hard on her
um you know like when she's doing her
schoolwork
she gets really stressed out when she
doesn't get grades you know she gets a
good grade she gets emotional it's been
really hard for her and
i'm worried that if she goes on to do
three more years of school that it will
take a toll on
on her mental health and my question is
how can i help her to
understand that she needs to do what's
best for her happiness and
if she does go on to physical therapy
school how can i help her
to handle school more calmly and
so her life isn't miserable for four
more years you know
sounds like this has been really hard on
you
i mean yeah tell me about that
well yeah just like you know when she's
studying she's very irritable
and um hard to deal with
and you know she doesn't want me around
when she's studying sometimes or
so hey listen did you hear all the
things you just said
you said she doesn't want you around she
gets irritable when you're around
it sounds like you might be the problem
not school
push back on that
uh like are you creating a
like a safe like
fun lively environment for her and then
a quiet
safe environment for her to study get
through this stuff
or are you somebody who's like hey why
don't you just do it like this how long
is he taking why are you taking so long
it doesn't matter you just got a b dude
shake it off which one of those guys are
you
no i definitely try my best to you know
provide a safe place for her to
to study and learn and i support her and
everything she does
i don't i don't um criticize her for
studying too long or anything like that
i mean i'm definitely there
trying to help her navigate school as
best as she can
um more of her problem is she's more of
a perfectionist you know
and she wants to be perfect
in school and like i said if she doesn't
get super good grades and it's really
hard on her
okay so at the end of the day
you can't i mean you can't there's
nothing there's there's nothing you can
say to her to be like hey why don't you
be less perfectionist
and should be like oh you know what
you're right i'll shake that off
um what you can do
is provide a space for her to get really
excited when she gets good grades and to
get really frustrated when she doesn't
get good grades
and then to come back and bounce back
you can
like being in school together is hard
man
my wife and i both were in grad school
together and then i went back to school
and we had two kids i mean it's a mess
dude it's hard
um sometimes folks temporary happiness
like when they're going through grad
school
is the happiness is the growing season
right it's like doing squats nobody
likes doing squats
um but you know that when you're pushing
that hard
the benefit on the back end is going to
be so great right
same as grad school dude same as is any
school and when you're invested you do
get emotional
and it is hard and you do lean into it
um
and so i would be willing to bet dude
and this isn't me trying to clown on you
this is me
like talking to myself 10 years ago 15
years ago
i bet you've got a lot of solutions and
recommendations and thoughts and answers
for her
and right now she's just trying to get
to school and
that ends up you end up becoming almost
another assignment for her
because she's got to make sure that
you're okay too and she's got to make
sure that
she's still filling the blank x y and z
too
and that becomes so heavy and so much
and so i'd love for you to create a
universe where y'all could
go out one day and talk about what the
future looks like have y'all done that
what is that what is that why does she
want to be a physical therapist what
world is she trying to create there
um well she has always had that goal
you know since she was a little girl she
talks about that's been
one of the things she's always wanted to
do um i always wanted to be a baseball
player
until somebody threw the ball like 90
miles an hour by me then i was like no
i'm good with that i'm not going to not
this is going to be the job for me so
it's got to be more than i've wanted to
do it for a long time something else is
driving her
yeah um the other thing i would say um
is she before we got married you know we
always talked about this
she has she thought she was scared that
her getting married at such a young age
would
might stop her from reaching that goal
too so it's been hard for me to
really show her we have been married for
that long we've been waiting for about
five months
um it's been hard for me to show her
that that i'm truly supportive
of her goals and i'm going to do
everything that i can to
help her reach that goal but bro it
doesn't sound like you
are sounds like you want her just to
like dude just get your degree and let's
go do something
else
and just be honest with with yourself if
is that the case
no no really john i mean i i really
want her to to do that and i want to see
her happy and
um so you can reach her goals um
does she have does she have permission
does she have permission to quit
to quit yeah yeah
i mean does she know that that if she
was like hey i don't want to go to grad
school anymore
that you would hug her just the same as
if she's like man i can't wait to go to
grad school
oh yeah definitely
a few months ago my wife's working
through some stuff she's been reading a
lot
on some new topics on some new like just
existential stuff and
um i won't go into the details because
it's personal but
at one point i said hey listen if you
end up
over here thinking this i'll still love
you
and we'll have so much fun with it it'd
be a wild adventure
and her shoulders just dropped and i
didn't realize how much she was
carrying around not only what she was
wrestling with
but what my reaction would be to what
she was wrestling with
that she would was also carrying what's
gonna happen if i land over here or over
here or over here or if i
stay keep my same thoughts on this these
things i'm thinking through
and working through what's my husband
gonna think what's he gonna do
is he's still gonna love me the same is
he gonna stick around you know all those
things that just start to
spin out and get crazy right
yeah and y'all been married five months
how much how long y'all date before this
um a little over a year how old are you
i'm 23. how old is she she's 21.
okay so here's what i want you to do man
i want you to
take her out this week okay i don't want
you to take a piece of paper and tell
her some idiot on the radio
told you to do this i want you to
write down with her sitting there
watching you
all the things that you love about her
the way she moves her mouth when she
laughs the way she
leaves glasses all over the place the
way all these little
idiosyncrasies five months in all these
things that you love about her
that you love her drive where she's
going the fact that she
is trying to get through school as a 21
she is just
she is beating herself up over it and
then i want you to
right um with her sitting there
i want you to hold that pen and i want
you to ask her what are ways i can love
we're five months
in what are ways i can love you best
and let her tell you so you got to go
first so you can
you can set this table here right but
then i want you to let her speak into it
and i don't want you to ask her what are
the things you love about me man
i want you just to make this completely
about
her her and her and i want you to hold
that pin and look her in the eye and say
how can i love you
because i want to be so good at it and
then when she asks questions like well
why are you asking this whatever be like
you talk to yourself in a way that
drives me crazy because i would never
let some dude at a bar talk to you the
way you talk to yourself
and so i want to create a world where
you can talk so good about yourself
sometimes i think you love school and
can't wait to go to grad school
sometimes
i think you don't like school anymore
you're burnt out but you feel this drive
and i want to keep loving you and
supporting you
how can i best do that and that ends up
becoming
a really good entry point into this
conversation because if you just show up
tonight and say hey dude
why don't you just quit school dude
don't go to grad school her worst fears
become true
yeah and if you just sit on the couch
with a video controller in your hand and
i'm i'm just picking on you dude i don't
know if that's true
and she's studying and studying and
studying you're like keep going babe
you're doing good from the other room
that's not helpful either right i want
you to get really tactical and practical
and
show her don't just tell her show her
you're all in you're five months
and then you've got to be okay in your
heart what if she says dude i really
really want to go to grad school
and be a physical therapist really bad
you've got to look up and realize it's
gonna be three more years of your life
you're gonna be 26 years old
if she says that paul are you in yeah
all in i'm a hornet that's so good man
you love this girl i love her so much
she's awesome
what does what does she's awesome mean
i mean she's just really the perfect
girl for me
i mean we get along super great and
we have fun together and we
have goals to just create a happy life
together and i'm just trying to
figure out how i can help her to be the
happiest she can be
all right so let's stop using the word
happy and let's use the word joyful
and here's the difference happy means
anything uncomfortable we do away with
any season or period of discomfort or
hard stuff we try to cover up and
wallpaper over
joyful means we sacrifice we work really
hard
for a good night's sleep for peace
for long-term goals right and so i don't
want you to focus on making her happy in
fact there's a lot of research
out and there's a real big study that
just came out like last week or this
week
that the harder you chase happy the less
happy overall in your life you become
i think it's it's a it's a western
pathology right we have made the pursuit
of happiness our god
and it's killing us slowly but surely
diseases of despair dude
we're collapsing under the weight of i
need to be happy need to be happy which
we've
moved to i need to be comfortable which
means i need to have everything the way
i like it
right i'm not saying that you i'm saying
that's us as a culture
and so i don't want you to focus on her
happiness
i want you to focus focus on her joy and
that means she's going to have hard
workouts that means she's going to
have hard seasons where she's in grad
school or have hard seasons of morning
when she decides to quit grad school
and you're going to be there to hold her
arms up when she's tired you're going to
be there to make sure the dishes and
laundry's done for
three years because she's running and
gun and doing clinicals and working so
hard
you're gonna be there for her and there
for her and there for her and she's
gonna be there for you too this is not
that one-sided of a thing right y'all
are both in this together
here but i want to make sure that she
knows
that you are all all in and give her
permission to quit
and give her permission to keep going
and if you don't have the tools i know
in your in your heart and spirit and
mind
you want to be the guy that makes sure
she's like supported but you may not
have those tools
i did not i did not have those tools my
tools were do whatever you want i'm out
of here
and i've had to learn them and learn
them and then learn them again and then
learn them again
and just a few weeks ago a couple months
ago i just said it
i'll still love you no matter what and
it was like
watching my wife exhale is both
beautiful and it breaks my heart
because usually the tension she holds is
something that i haven't given her
so start with a dinner start with a
blank piece of paper and a pin
all the things you love about her and
then ask her how can you love her better
five months in start building those
foundations
don't whine don't complain get to work
get to
work you're building something special
brother and then plan what your future
is going to look like
not just i want to make you happy what
is this going to look like paint a
really clear picture together then
you'll work towards it
all right brother thank you so much for
your call man um
you're a good guy paul you're a good guy
month five is
hard getting married at 23 is hard
brother
hang in there hang in there all right as
we wrap it up um
let's do this one dude because sometimes
you just got to go with the truth and
the truth is that in 2005
partnering with y cl wyclef john
shakira dropped magic she dropped to
magic because you know why
hers mine james kelly's all of us
our hips don't lie it's released in 2005
shakira writes this masterpiece just
like this
ladies up in here tonight no fighting we
got the refugees up in here
no fighting no fighting shakira shakira
she said her own name twice
in the first line of her own song how
dope is that
i never really knew that she could dance
like this she make a man want to speak
spanish
shakira shakira again her own name twice
poets how do you like that oh baby when
you talk like that you make a woman go
mad so be wise
and keep on c reading the signs of my
body uno dos tres cuatro
that's one two three four for you
non-spanish-speaking poets
i'm on tonight you know my hips don't
lie no fighting
i'm starting to feel it right all the
attraction the tension don't you see
baby
this is perfection and this has been the
dr john dalone's show